[Musik]
eigentlich wollte ich einen richtigen
kirche starten aber dann habe ich
gemerkt ach ja ich will der kirche
scheiße und dann meinte das zdf was ist
denn mit einer ruine von der kirche
perfekt eine bis auf die grundmauern
zerstörte kirche das ist genau die dosis
gotteshaus mit der ich klarkomme jesus
wäre jetzt natürlich empört wenn ich das
sagen würde oder
sollte warum musst du dich denn jetzt
noch bei der kirche ein weil die kirche
sich ganz schön krass in unserem kram 1
nicht viel zu sehr bevor du jetzt bevor
du jetzt ausrastet ich kenne viele leute
bei der kirche die super arbeit machen
und jesus für mich gehört eindeutig dazu
wie du das machst mit dem pro teil mit
dem wein teilen aber dann könntest du
einfach mal anfangen staat und kirche zu
teilen du ich muss los ich hab noch ein
termin
deutschland ist eigentlich nicht
religiöser start sagt das grundgesetz
klingt super heißt doch nicht viel denn
was in deutschland fehlt es laizismus
also die klare trennung von staat und
religion laizismus sagt religion ganz
gerne machen aber es reine privatsache
ist wie mit onanieren zu hause schön in
der fußgängerzone unangenehm diese
trennung von kirche und staat ist in
deutschland aber gar nicht vorgesehen
und genau das ist das problem es gibt
uralte sonderrechte für die christlichen
kirchen die nie abgeschafft wurden in
bayern zum beispiel zahlt das land nicht
nur die gehälter von allen 15 bischöfen
sondern auch die von mehr als hundert
weiteren kirchlichen spitzen gestellten
unter anderem kriegen die bischöfe vom
freistaat bayern sogar ihre wohnungen
gestellt und das geld für die
kirchenleute kommt nicht aus der
kirchensteuer sondern von uns allen egal
ob jemand an gott glaubt an mohammed
oder die möglichkeit dass jemand anderes
als bayern münchen meister wird das
gesetz dass all das regelt stammt im
kern aus dem jahr 1803 das ist so lange
her damals galt in deutschland noch die
todesstrafe durch verbrennung am
lebendigen leibe auch die idee von der
mitarbeiter ab sind wo war ich da gerne
hintertürchen offen lassen würde für
leute die motivationssprüche als
wandtattoo an ihre wohnzimmerwand
geschrieben haben entschuldigung steht
bei ihnen wenn das leben dir eine
zitrone gibt machen im monat raus ja
dann müssen wir sie jetzt leider
anzünden ja noch da mal eine limonade
draus
[Musik]
eine weitere regelung aus der zeit der
staat zahlt den kirchen jedes jahr 500
millionen euro weil mal von denen
irgendwann gebäude enteignet wurden als
entschädigung was ist das denn für eine
entschädigung kann der staat mir bitte
sofort meinen fiat 500 enteignen ich
würde gerne gerne porsche als
entschädigung nehmen dankeschön warum
sind die mitgliedsbeiträge für die
kirche überhaupt nicht steuer wenn ich
den verein auf mache dann muss ich meine
mitgliedsbeiträge selber ein schreiben
egal wie gemeinnützig ich bin mein
verein kann sich um dreibeinige
straßenkatzen aus rumänien mit
laktoseintoleranz kümmern scheißegal ich
muss die rechnung selber schreiben bei
den christlichen kirchen dagegen kümmern
sich die finanziell warum die
angestellten des staates also unsere
angestellten sind das inkassounternehmen
der kirche niemand hat solche
privilegien
noch besser wird die sache wenn man
austreten will das geht nicht einfach
per brief oder mail du kannst doch nicht
einfach das formular an die kirchentüren
nageln wie früher
man muss bis zu sechs monate auf einen
termin warten dann persönlich zu einer
behörde gehen und sogar noch 30 euro
austritts gebühr bezahlen
austritts gebühr wenn die kirche keine
kirche wäre sondern eine firma das
illegal gut meine kirche firma wäre und
zwar meine dann gibts auch besseres
nächsten mal kann ich der leib christi
auf naxos mit käse sein
[Musik]
das dsw kirchensteuer zahlt bekommt
dafür sehr wenig gute taten der großteil
geht einfach für die personalkosten der
bistümer und gemeinden darauf hätte
jesus damals schon so ein
personalschlüssel hat die geschichte
hieß jesus und seine 12.000
verwaltungsangestellte
[Musik]
das wirklich krass wie wenig
kirchensteuern soziales fließt bestes
beispiel der katholische
wohlfahrtsverband caritas die sind
tatsächlich kein witz deutschlands
größter privater arbeitgeber mit mehr
als 650.000 mitarbeiter/innen betreibt
die caritas über 2500 einrichtungen soll
und wie viel geld aus der kirchensteuer
landet zb in den katholischen kirchen
hunden
erwarte wir machen es spannend
nichts gar nichts null zero
- vielen dank war super
keine sorge das ist nicht in der kirche
ich sage es nochmal weil es so
unglaublich klingt katholische von der
caritas betriebene krankenhäuser die
keine gelegenheit auslassen zu sagen wie
gut sie sind sind komplett vom staat
finanziert die diakonie den gleichen job
bei der evangelischen kirche macht
funktioniert genauso wenn es nur um geld
geht und nicht um frauen als fahrer ist
man sich doch überraschend oft einig gut
aber gäbe ist die kirche nicht müssen
wir eben anders bezahlt die sache ist
die christlichen kirchen sind noch nicht
mal geile arbeitgeber der stadt
finanziert zwar zu 100 prozent aber die
kirche kann mitarbeitende aus den
absurdesten gründen kündigen zum
beispiel wenn sie homosexuell sich
scheiden lassen oder die falsche
konfession haben private firmen oder dem
status was verboten nur die kirchen
bekommen eine ausnahme weil sie sagen oh
ja ja gott entschieden mit den schulen
vor 2000 jahren und wir alle finanzieren
diese kleine zeitkapsel noch dazu haben
mitarbeitende einfach kein streikrecht
deswegen konnte letztes jahr die caritas
eine tarif vereinigung verhindern die
das leben von mehr als einer million
menschen in der altenpflege massiv
verbessert hätte übrigens caritas ist
lateinisch für nächstenliebe und da
haben wir nur über den
gesundheitsbereich geredet ein
katholisches gymnasium hat neulich ein
lehrer vor die tür gesetzt weil der
seinen lebensgefährten heiraten wollte
also liebe deinen nächsten ja aber nur
zu hause und den raum ohne fenster
ich war selber in einem katholischen
kindergarten in dem einmal die woche der
vater vorbeikam und uns sagte wie toll
gott ist dann nach links auf die
katholische grundschule einfach weil es
nichts anderes in der nähe meines dorfes
gehabt ich hatte damals noch glück dass
ich eine tolle religionslehrerin hatte
aber nicht wegen ihrer ausbildung
sondern trotz denn die leute die an den
unis die religionslehrerinnen ausbilden
werden nicht von der uni ausgesucht
sondern von den kirchen an einer uni wo
es um wissenschaft geht das ist als
würde shell die ausbildung von
klimaforschern organi ich bin total
dafür etwas über religion zu lernen ja
aber schulen sind doch nicht dafür da
für die kirchen mitglieder zu werben in
bioläden sicher auch etwas über bäume
nicht wie ich selber am baum werde
also das wichtigste ist nicht bewegen
und
sich gar nicht bewegen egal was passiert
das beschreibt die christlichen kirchen
in deutschland schon sehr gut vor allem
wenn es um den missbrauchs politik der
katholischen kirche geht mindestens
3677 minderjährige sollen von 1946 bis
2014 missbraucht worden seien von
angehörigen der katholischen kirche und
das sind nur die von dem man gesichert
weiß neuesten untersuchungen zufolge
geht man mittlerweile sogar von bis zu
6.000 missbraucht haben seit den 50er
jahren aus und das alleine im bistum
münster
das sind zehnmal so viele wie hier
stühle stehen
die kirche selbst bringt verdachtsfälle
so gut wie nie selbst zur anzeige und
behindert die aufklärung wo sie kann in
der katholischen kirche gilt ein eigenes
kirchenrecht der kodex loris canonica
und man hört schon am namen das sind
ganz frisch ist da gibt es seit den
80ern ein eigenes kapitel das sich mit
sexuellen verfehlungen von
kirchenmitgliedern beschäftigt also was
passiert mit den riesigen überraschung
meistens gar nichts und die kirche
meldet die taten auch nicht der
deutschen staatsanwaltschaft warum hat
sich die kirche immer schon selber drum
gekümmert durch vertuschung meine damen
und herren wie immer nichts schuldig das
funktioniert nur bei der staat beide
augen zudrückt nach wie vor hat in
deutschland noch nie 'ne
staatsanwaltschaft eine
bistumsverwaltung durchsucht und
missbrauch an minderjährigen
schutzbefohlenen verjährt in vielen
fällen bereits nach fünf jahren
fünf wer steuern hinterzieht muss sie
nach zehn jahren noch zurückzahlen warum
hat die kirche in der deutschen politik
sonne krasse lobby weiß leider niemand
also ich dränge niemanden meine skepsis
auf aber dann drängt ihr liebe kristen
mir bitte nicht euer weltbild auf es sei
denn er weiß mir das mit dem leben nach
dem tod da können wir noch mal
miteinander reden daher meine frage gibt
es im himmel nachos mit käse und wenn ja
könnte ich da schon mal vorbestellt
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt haye